大家好我是来自蚂蚁蜜蚕的周艾辉
今天由我给大家来介绍密台道目型
今天我们的课程将分为四部分
第一部分是我们的问题定义
第二部分将介绍密台道目型
第三部分是教大家从零开始上手
搭建一个密台道目型退离服务
第四部分是对我们的课程做一个总结
首先是我们课程的第一部分
就问题定义了
随着AI时代的到零
道目型正在走向产业深度应用
那么需要更多高质量的数据
专业性的数据
那么对于行业道目型
构建者而言
其实数据短缺是一大难题
但一直同时对于数据和模型提供方而言
可能他们是有高质量的数据
但是又没有能力构建的一大模型
同时他们又会担心数据安全问题
不敢新的外部机构
使用他们的专业数据
那么如何确保数据和模型难安全
又是他们担忧的问题
那与此同时
对于模型使用方而言
query可能是涉及到
个人隐私和商业机密
那么query的安全
也是大家比较关心的问题
那么这些数据安全的问题
是极耐解决的
主要的大模型往后下一步的发展
那么我们怎么解决这个问题呢
通过密台道目型
其实我们可以解决这个数据和模型难安全问题
同时也可以保护query的安全
我们最终来实现高价值的数据教数应用
那么对问题的定义进行了产数呢
那我们接下来介绍密台大模型
那么在介绍密台大模型之前呢
我们先介绍一下机密计算
机密计算呢
它的英文叫做confidential computing
那么机密计算讲的一个主要的概念是
数据使用者安全
就引寓子的一个安全
那么数据呢
其实在它的生命周期里面呢
其实我们可以概括为三大部分
第一部分是叫at rest
就可以理解为是纯处
然后第二部分是inch and z 传输
第三部分就是说使用中
那么数据的这三个环节呢
其实都比较说纯处安全
其实大家可能结束了也比较多
传输安全
比如说trs加密的传输安全
这个也是非常经典的一个安全
那么数据使用中的安全呢
就是机密计算抢掉的一个概念
那么通过保护内传中的数据
比如说对内传期间加密了
然后来保护数据使用中的安全
那么机密计算呢
通常会记以Ti来实现
Ti呢
它的中文一般会叫可信执行环境
那么我们可以这么理解Ti
它是一个隔离的环境
然后这个环境呢
可以保护呢
只有被授权的代码才可以去执行
那么在Ti里面的数据呢
其实是就是从Ti的外面呢
是没法去读或者去篡改的
那这是它的一个核心概念
那么Ti里面经常会有一个名词叫做应用非地
那么非地呢
你可以理解为是Ti的一个具体的一个实力
然后在这个非地里面呢
它就提供了一个隔离的环境
可以保护特定的代码数据
那么这个机密计算呢
它的威胁模型讲的是说
对于营厂商或者说其他的角色而言呢
当你在云上去部署你的代码数据的时候
你这些代码数据在执行过程中
云厂商和其他方都是没法去获取你的数据和代码的
那么Ti呢
其实有三大特性
大家这三个特性是相对于R1E来讲
R1E呢
是其实中文会叫做副执行环境
那就是我们经常日常中所见到的
就是操作系统或者应用
其实他们都跑在一个明文的环境里面
明文的机器上面
那么通常我们把它叫做R1E的应用和R1E的OS
那么Ti呢
它突然会跑在Ti的硬件上面
在这个Ti硬件上面之上呢
它会运行所谓的
比如说Ti的一个操作系统或者运行室
在上面是跑的所谓的Ti的应用
那么Ti拥有三个非常重要的特性
那么第一个呢叫做隔离
就说首先R1E的负责蓝阶呢
它是被排除在Ti之外的
所以Ti它的攻击面是比较小的
然后它的Ti的安全性呢
主要依赖它致解
它不依赖R1E
那么第二个特性呢是说加密
那么通常来说Ti的硬件呢
它会保证Ti以R1E是强隔离的
而且Ti的硬件通常呢
会提供那层加密的能力
然后这样它可以防止Ti外面
或者R1E的环境去堵Ti的内存
或者去修改Ti的内存
那么Ti的第三个重要的特性是叫远程证明
那么就是说Ti硬件呢
可以作为一个性能根
它提供了一套远程证明的机制
就是可以让用户去对Ti的环境做一个验证
确保这个是一个真实的Ti的硬件
构成了一个Ti的环境
而非一个虚假的Ti环境
那么通过这三个重要的特性呢
Ti其实就可以实现可用而不可见
也就是所谓的那个机密器材强调的
DataInU字的安全
那么接下来我们介绍密台大模型
然后中间这个大图呢
这个其实是讲述了整个大模型
全都是密台流转的一个过程
那么可以可以这么看这个图
就是我们首先讲大模型推理的部分
然后可以看上面这一块
大模型推理呢
首先它是说要有一个模型持有者提供大模型
那么我们可以看上面这个联络
那么模型持有者呢
我们会先对它的模型做一个加密
之后上传放到云端
云端呢会把这个大模型
放加载到Ti里面
然后在Ti里面就是拉起一个大模型推理服务
最后形成一个对外的推理的一个API
那么用户呢
真正的用户呢
可以通过这个API
或者它可以通过一个外部轮曲
或者通过SDK
那么可以这个大模型的推理服务
进行一个加密的聊天
那这就是这就是所谓的
我们前面讲的那个问题
定义里面的query的安全
然后这个这个列录是可以保护query安全的
同时也可以保护这个大模型部署的时候
的大模型本身的一个安全
那么大模型
这个权力对面第二块列录的主要是下半部分
这里讲的是说
那大模型的可能通常的会涉及到一个
比如我们构建一个人一个大模型
可能会对大模型做一个后训练
比如说SFT或者说强化学习
那做完之后呢
你可能会带它做一个评测
那么首先这个后训练和评测的所有过程
是在T里面进行的
那么在这个后训练和评测的过程中
其实会涉及到主要是有两方
一方是模型持有的
一方是数据持有的
那么他们的分别贡献的模型和数据
当然也有可能这个模型
可能是一个开源的模型
这个都有可能
然后他们分别会把自己的数据和模型
就是加密
然后也是放到云上
之后呢他们会对这个
就是我们会有一个模块叫做
密台数据交代管理器这个模块
然后这个模块呢
它做了两个功能
一个是就密奥管理
一个是做授权策略的教育
那么密奥管理是什么意思呢
就是说模型和数据都是被加密放到云上的
那么他们的密奥是被托管在
这个所谓的密台交代管理器里面
那同时呢
这个密台交代管理器
是也是跑在T里面的
所以它本身也是安全的
那另外一块呢
还有一个所谓的授权策略是什么意思呢
就是说模型持有者
或者说数据的持有者
他们可以对自己的数据或者模型去
先领它的授权的那个使用的策略
比如说数据持有者可以在策略里面写说
我的数据只能够用于做训练
但你不能拿来做其他的
那么这就是一个授权的策略
那么这些所谓的策略呢
其实也会由这个密台数据交代管理器管理起来
并且由它进行教验
这个教验是怎么做的呢
就是说
这个后训练和评测
这个在T里面跑的时候呢
比方他们去访问
去获取这个对应的加密的数据
或者加密的模型的密要的时候呢
那么这个密台交代管理器的手间
会对这个它的那个数据
或者模型的那个数据策略进行一个教验
那么它会检查
比如说你
比如说数据持有者
它会要求你是一个后训练
那么它就会签检查
你是不是一个后训练的代码
如果不是的话
它就会拒绝把密要给你
如果是的话
它会把密要给到这个
所谓的后训练的这个代码
然后这个
这就是一个整体的一个当模型的
权力诺密台流转的一个过程
那么接下来我们对这个流程做一个拆解吧
就是
就是我们详细
先介绍一下
所谓的这个当模型的一个推理的
这个Q率保护是怎么实现的呢
那么首先我们看这个图
这个图分为左右两大部分
左边是我们的一个推理客户端
可以理解为是用户端
用户可能是通过网页
或者说是直接调用一个API
或者说通过USDK的这种方式
会去对右边的这个
所谓的推理服务进行一个调用
那么右边的推理服务呢
是跑在T里面的
那么这里的过程大概是这样的
就说首先这个推理客户端呢
会对这个所谓的推理服务呢
做一个免成认证的请求
然后在那么推理服务呢
会在它的内部
在这个内部呢
会生成一个所谓的
免成认证的一个报告
然后这个报告呢
其实是会有那个
表的T呢
这个硬件的芯片里面
内置的私要进行一个签名
然后这个免成认证报告呢
通常会包含
比如说它的硬件的信息
固件的信息
软件的信息
配置信息等等等等
那么之后呢
这个免成认证报告
就我们第三步
会不会发挥
会给推理客户端
那么推理客户端
拿到这个免成认证报告的同时呢
它会拿到这个推理服务的这个功耀
就是功耀和免成认证的报告
会一起被带回给这个推理客户端
那么推理客户端
其实就可以去找这个可信根机构
就说所谓的这个T的这个硬件
肯定这些环境硬件的
这个背书的这个厂商
比如说国内的话
可能比如说是蚂蚁蜜蒜的T
就是蚂蚁蜜蒜
或者说其他的可信的这三方
那么找这个可信根机构呢
去验了这个免成认证报告
那么它主要是说
为了确认这个环境的确认
是一个真实的一个T的环境
那么这个演成的报告
教验通过之后呢
那么用户呢
其实就可以相信的
这是一个推理服务
确实跑在T里面
而且它的功耀是可以信任的
那么就回到了
就开始进入到第五步
第五步呢
就是说会对推理型要做一个加密
它大概的原理是说
首先它会用功耀
对这个数据的密要做一个加密
我们可以看到这一个
这是一个钥匙的形状
它是一个数据密要
就是在推理科物丹自己产生的
那么用功耀加密这个数据密要
同时用这个数据密要
去加密这个推理型球的内容
那么我们会得到一个加密后的数据密要
还有一个加密后的推理型球
那么之后呢
推理科物丹会把这个加密的推理型
那个推理型球和密要呢
都会发送给推理服务
那么推理服务就来到第七步了
推理服务呢
它会用自己的
因为它有私要
它会用这个私要
解密这个数据密
加密后的数据密要
那么它就会得到一个
明文的数据密要
那么它再用这个数据密要
去解密这个推理型球
那就可以得到
最终的一个明文的推理型球
那它之后再把这个推理型球
发送给它自己
内部的大模型服务
那么就是
碟八博大模型做它
那大模型呢
会对你的问题
做一个回答
得到一个做答的内容
那么同时呢
这个推理服务呢
并不会直接把这个做答内容
直接就返回给推理科物丹
它会先对这个做答内容
做一个加密
它的密要呢
也是这个科物丹自己发过来
这个数据密要
那么加密后的做答内容呢
会被返回给推理科物丹
那么最终推理科物丹再用自己的
这个数据密要呢
对这个做答内容做一个解密
最后得到一个明文的做答内容
这就是一个完整的
一个碟八博大模型推理的
一个球里保护的一个链路
那么接下来我们讲一下
那个碟八博大模型的
后训练数据和模型保护的链路
然后这个链路呢
会比球里保护呢
要更复杂一点
但其实基本原理是差不多的
然后在这里呢
其实有三大块的模块
你最左边是机构
你可以理解
为是后训练
因为它可能设计到的是数据
或者模型的
那么这个机构指的
就是说数据或者模型的机构方
那么中间呢
是一个密态数据交代管理服务
就前面也讲过这个服务的
这个服务的主要作用
是为了拖拐这个数据的密要
同时呢
对它这个密要的使用呢
做一个健全
这个服务呢
其实本身也是要泡在T里面的
这样的话才能保证
它是安全和可信的
那么最右边呢
是我们的后训练应用
它也是泡在T里面的
这个比如说
像SFT啊
或者RL啊
或者评测量化等等啊
这个都
我们就把它统充为叫做后训练应用
那么这里的具体的流程
那么从第一步开始是这样的
首先呢
是说这个机构
会对这个密态数据交代管理服务
做一个演成能证
那么原理呢
其实跟前面是类似的
就是说这个交代管理服务呢
它还会继续升到一个演成能报告
就是第二步
之后把这个演成能报告呢
返回给这个机构机构呢
再去找可信的
跟机构呢
作为一个认证
最后呢
确定这个演成能报告是可信的
从而证明这个
交代管理服务呢
是泡在一个T里面
这个步骤就是第二步的
为了方便呢
我们就把这一些过程给省略掉了
那么第二步完了之后呢
就是机构就可以确信这个管理
交代管理服务是可信的
那么它就可以把自己的
用这个
交代管理服务的功耀呢
去对它自己的数据呢
的密要呢
做一个加密
当然它自己的数据本人是用
机构自己的数据密要做加密了
那么这样的话就得到了
几个几块一种
一块是说加密后的数据
对吧
还有一块是
用这个管理服务的功耀加密
过后的这个数据密要
那么同时呢
还有一块就是说
那个数据的授权
使用策略
前面也提过啊
就是说
这个数据或者模型的提供方呢
可以指定一个使用的策略
就是说
允许这个数据或者模型
被怎么使用
那么接下来呢
就是第四步和第五步了
第五步的话
就是说
我们有了数据密号的
有数据策略呢
那么它会
会被发送给
交代管理服务
然后交代管理服务
会把它管起来
那么同时呢
这个机构呢
就是第六步了
它会把这个
加密之后的数据呢
或者模型呢
会上到云端
就是我们放在云存储
当然这个有可能
这个开环境啊
定位就反而是放在
一个存储的地方
那么做完这些
准备的工作之后呢
其实我们就要开始进行
一个后训练嘛
那么这个就开始
进入到那个第七步了
那假如说我们开始
执行一个后训练的应用
比如说我们执行一个强化学习
那么它就需要访问
这个数据和模型嘛
那么就是第七步开始
那个后训练应用呢
它会先去找这个数据
加拿大管理服务呢
去请求数据庙
那么数据加拿大管理服务呢
会先对这个
做一个健全
这个健全的逻辑呢
是说
大概的逻辑是说
首先会去
它会看见这个数据
或者模型的
一个使用的数据的策略
那么你这个应用时候
满足这个策略
那么只有在这个策略
被满足之后呢
才会去用
解开这个数据的庙
把这个庙
通过
加密的方式呢
给到这个后训练应用
这里注意
这个密钥本身也是被加密的
也就是说第九步
它发生数据密钥
这个数据密钥呢
其实是用
这个所谓的应用的功耀加密
所以这个过程也是安全的
那么拿到密钥之后呢
后训练应用呢
就要去下载真正的
这个数据或者模型了
那它这个下载
就就是一个整合的过程
那么第十一步呢
就讲的是说
现在
后训练应用呢
它现在又有数据了
对吧
有加密或者数据或者模型
同时它也有对应的密钥
那么它就可以
通过这个密钥去解密这个数据
或者模型
得到这个明文的数据
那么之后呢
它就可以开始进行真正的后训练了
那么它拿到这个
预料的数据啊
然后记忆当模型
它就可以做微调
做墙外学习等等等等
那么接下来
我们介绍一些应用案例吧
然后
就是这个应用案例讲的是说
国内的模TOP7IM
这个其实就是大家应该都知道
就是国内非常有没有
这顶尖的计价了
然后其实他们就用了
我们的密钥当模型技术
来保护这个当模型的curie安全
那么他遇到的问题
其实
我们就开始介绍的
那个问题是类似的
就是说
对于这个IMB端客户而言
他们在IMB内呢
其实有大量使用当模型的需求的
但是这个当模型的需求
使用过程中呢
其实它会涉及到
B端客户的核心数据资产
那么B端客户呢
他又很担心自己的数据被泄漏
所以他也不敢说
直接去使用一个
他不敢信任的外部的
一个第三方的一个模型
那么我们是怎么解决
他这个问题的呢
其实就是说
我们通过前面讲的
这个所谓的密钥当模型
这个方案
因为他提供了一个
curie安全的保护嘛
那么这个
这个
那么这个IMB上面提供的这个
AI应用的
他就可以机忧我们的密钥当模型
去保护用户的
那个敏感数据
比如他的私料的消息啊
权消息啊
文档库瓦的程标
权文件等等等等
这些东西都可以通过
前面讲的那个加密的链路保护起来
那么最后呢
模型的输入呢
他是通过一个密用的形式
被发送给一个云旦当模型密钥退离服务
那么同时呢
这个密钥当模型的退离服
他返回给自个爱养模的
他返回的也是一个密闻
那么这样的话
这个
从这个输入到输出
整体都是一个密钥保护的过程
那么最终呢
保护了这个企业的
商业机密和隐私安全
那么另外一个应用案例是说
大模型的密钥知识库
那这个这个案例想啊
是说
就是现在其实很多企业
会还有一些个人用户
其实他是希望有自己的一些
知识库的
然后他们希望用自己的一些
专业知识去构建自己的一些
知识库的能力呢
然后通过这个都
这通过这些知识能力呢
然后让自己的
业务呢
就是受益
但是呢
通常这个过程
那么他也需要使用到外部的大模型
就是
因为有很多企业或者个人
其实他也无法负担得起
自己部署一整套
大模型的服务
那么所以他们就会导致
他们有很多私有的文章
其实他不敢
就给大模型去用
那么如果有了我们这个密钥大模型
他们这个
这个场景就可以得到一个解决
那么
那么这个解决方案呢
大概是这样的
就是说
首先这会有一个端侧的知识库
这个端可能是说用户端
就是比方说是
一个企业的内部的一个域
或者是个人用户的自己的一个
本地的一个服务器
或者电脑啊
然后在这个端上呢
其实是有一个
可以认为是有一个本地的知识库的
可能里面涉及到一些
企业的机密数据啊
或者是各地隐私一些文档
那么在这个端上呢
其实会有一个知识库
然后这个知识库呢
是一个可以对这个知识做一个
检索
之后呢
这个检索出来的知识呢
在家常用户想要
就是问答的一个问题呢
就是Q类的内容
组合到一起呢
它会进行一个加密
然后这个用户的问题和这个
检索在知识片呢
被加密之后呢
就送入到这个云丹大模型
云丹大模型提供
其实就提供了
我们会提供通用的大模型
吹着大模型的一些服务
然后同时呢
因为它的Q类是一个加密的
它返回的也是一个
模型的数据也是加密的
都是密闻的
那么之后呢
这个对于这个用户而言
或者说对于这个企业而言
它就不用担心
它的商业的机密
或者个人的隐私呢
被泄漏
那么这个案例呢
其实就可以保护企业
和个人的商业机密和隐私安全
同时呢
因为有了这套发案呢
就是用户
或者说企业呢
它敢去使用它的知识库的
就是它敢去用
就是它也不需要说
一定要在本地
自己部署一套大模型的推理服务
然后这样的话可以
基于这个知识呢
它就可以获得一个
更好的一个业务场景的使用
它的答案的可靠性呢
还有它的商业品
都会得到提升呢
同时呢
在云丹的话
因为我们可以
做一些更多的使用
就是我们可以
跟针对客户的场景
做一些
这个垂裂的大模型
然后提供更丰富的领域
因为我们可以
通过密带的方式
去保护这个领域的知识
那么就预约着
我们有机会去训练出一个
更加高效
垂直专业的一个大模型
那么
接下来是
我们这个课程的第三块
就是我们会
教大家从零
开始搭建一个
密带大模型推理服务
那么
首先我们先介绍一下
CharsFlow
就是马尼米算
其实之前
开源过一套
记忆可静执行环境的一个
计算框架
叫CharsFlow
那么这个开源的地质
就贴在这里
大家心里可以去访问
那么CharsFlow呢
就是
左边是CharsFlow的
一个介绍的图
就是它
是在提议的
可静执行环境
这个
至上的购建了
一整套的
可静的应用
同时呢
它也提供了
一整套完整的密带
数据交量的一个管理服
包括它的数据的
宽语管控
安全加固等等
那么它支持
经济学习算法
还有深度学习
还有大模型数据分析等等
那么这里为什么说
我们要先介绍CharsFlow
是因为CharsFlow
提供了一套
就是
所谓的
机密计算的透明框架
那么简称叫CCTF
那么这套机制呢
可以帮助应用的
无缝迁移到机密的
迅速下面
去做一个安全的进行
那么这个框架的
原理是说
就是说
它会在一个机密信息机里面
去部署很多个set card
然后这个set card
可以提供远程认证的一个代理
或者说数据读写的代理
或者通信代理的功能
然后这些功能
可能对应用本体来讲
可能是无感的
那么这样的话
我们就可以通过
直接把应用放在
这个框架里面去运行
从而实现
一个密带的应用
那么接下来
我们对这个
问题的步骤做一个拆解
那么第一步呢
是环境准备
那么首先硬件呢
我们要建议
有一台X86的服务器
然后配备了GPU
最好是因为达了GPU
然后这里
如果你不是X86的机器的话
或者是ARM
或者其他的架构
这个建议可以参考
那个VARM的官网
有专门的说明
教你怎么去运行
那么这里
我来说一下
就是我
这里我没有去强调
说大家一定要准备一个
肯定资金环境的一个服务器
主要是考虑到大家
准备有这个
就是准备这个环境呢
可能是有一定的难度的
就是毕竟现在
有肯定资金环境的
这个机器
特别是配备GPU的机器
这个普及度并不高
所以我们这里
没有强制要求
但是它也不反而去
我们构建一个
密带当兵推理服务
只是说这个推理服务
它并不是真的跑在一个
真实的T的GPU的环境里面
如果大家真的有T的
真实的环境
其实也可以
用我们后续介绍的
一样的方式去部署
这个都是
就是原理是一样的
网络上的其实
大家要求比较简单
就是大家可以去
防护公网就可以的
因为下载模型是需要的
软件上就是
Python建议是大于等于
3.10版本
那么多可能建议是
19.03以上
或者更高一点也可以
那么接下来我们去部署
这个
第二步就是部署推理服务了
那么这个命令行
其实我们贴在这里的
那么这一整段的
这个代码的其实
我们都放在我们
开源的仓库里面的
所以呢大家可以按
这个命令上去执行
就是首先你要
get a column
我们的trust flow
这个代码仓库
之后进行到
我们的那个
实力的代码的
那个目录下面
之后我们只需要
执行dock-compose-up
这个命令就行了
如果一些顺利的话
你应该会看到
这个输出就是
这个WM会打出这样的
这个表明就是
它的服务已经启动了
OK的
那么最后
第三步呢
其实就是说
我们要去验证一下
这个代码仓库
对吧
我们要去访问它
那么我们可以
执行这个命令
就是说
首先我们就按照
我们必要的依赖
pip install
之后呢
我们就执行
我们的JW client
这个拍摄的脚本
那这个脚本
其实会做一些事情
就是它会去
访问这个
刚刚我们拉起来的
那个WM
这个代码仓服务
然后这个脚本里
就是它们
就问了
这个代码仓
一个人就你好
就是如果你这个
正常的话
你可以看到这些反尾
一个是说
这个模型的思考
它思考了一大段
把这个我们就忽略不堵了
之后呢
它给你回答
就说你好
有什么可以帮助你的吗
然后这个
在这个势力里面
其实我们
部署的
默论部署的是
一个千万三零点六B的模型
就大家如果有
有想法的话
可以换成
其他的模型
这个都没有关系的
那么这里呢
就是说
我们要介绍一下
这个里面就是
就是我们虽然是演示
但是我们要了解
就是说
这里到底是怎么做到
一个明太推理的对吧
前面我们介绍了
一个明太推理的内容
那么我们可以
自己有兴趣的其实
你可以打开这个脚本
看一下
就看看它到底做了啥
这里我做一个简单的介绍
就说这个脚本的
第一步其实就是
会对这个
弹幕性服务
本地做一个演册认证
然后或其他的功耀
那当然前面强调了
因为我们没有
说你一定要在一个
可信之心
环境的这个GPU的下面
去做一个
明太弹幕性的部署
就是你可以拿不同的
机器部署
我们可以理解为
是一个反正模式
它并不是一个真正的
一个T的原成认证
但是这个原理
其实是一样的意思
那么第一步
拿到这个功耀之后
其实就是这个脚本
会让这个功耀
对这个QD的内容
进行一个加密
那么之后这个脚本
其实就会把
这个加密合的请求
还有它的对话弥昂
发给这个弹幕性的推理服务
那么弹幕性的推理服务
其实会解密这个请求
然后对弹幕性
做一个回答
然后之后这个
回答的内容
也是加密的
加密的回答内容
会不会返回
给这个脚本
那么脚本之后
会用它的这个对话弥昂
去解密这个回答的内容
从而得到一个
明文的回答
其实就是大家可以
去看一下代码
其实它代码的逻辑
其实就是这样的一个逻辑
然后在这个过程中
其实我们可以
有兴趣还可以看见
就是在那个室内代码
下面有一个
Dock Compose的一个压模
就是大家可以看到
有一个
有一个压模的一个文件里面
其实是说
里面可以看到就是
这个整个大面推理服务
是怎么被部署起来的
就是我右边也解了些图
其实这个里面非常简单
一共就是有三个容器
那么前面两个容器
第一个是
我们的远程轮证的
这个塞德卡
就是说在第一个容器
第二个是我们的
Evoi的这个容器
第三个就是我们的
VM的这个景象的容器
那么其实这就是我们
就是前面我们强调过的
就是我们
Trustful能够提供了一整套的
这个所谓的透明化
变成空假cctf
那么这个所谓的这个
演出证证的
还有这里的Evoi
其实都是
就是Trustful能够提供的
就是你只要把它组装一起
然后放到你这个
推理的服务的前面
提前拉起
然后之后你就可以
正常拉起你的推理服务了
我们可以看到
这里的VM是完全和你
正常启动一个VM
是没有任何差别
就是你不用做任何改造
然后之后你就可以拉起
一个VM推理服务
然后之后你对外提供
这个推理的时候
你获得的是一个
Metai推理的能力
那么这就是我们的
Trustful带来的一个优势
那么最后一部分
第四部分其实就是
我们对课程
做一个快速简单的总结吧
其实我们这个课
其实主要讲了两块内容
第一块是说
我们介绍了一下
整体的这个Metai大帽型的
全能动Metai的一个原理
那么从
训练到推理
其实我们都介绍了
那么通过这个
Metai大帽型的
前练录的一个Metain
其实我们可以发现
它可以保护你的训练数据
保护Q率
也可以保护大帽型本身
那么这是我们整个课程的
第一块的主要的那种
第二块呢
其实说我们
也教了大家
怎么去从零开始
上手搭建一个
Metai大帽型推理服务
那么这个呢
是我们是基于Trustful的
CCTF
就是GimG算透明化框架
来实现的
然后通过这个框架
其实我们可以发现
非常可以
真的是可以零基础的
快速实现一个
Metai大帽型推理服务
就体现了
这个这套框架的优势
那么我们的课程呢
就到此就结束了
非常感谢大家的观看